BACK.
I WANT TO GO FORWARD.
>> Tammy: AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST
MARK STEYN JOINS US NOW.
I HAVE A FEELING YOU HAVE A FEW
THINGS TO SAY.
WELCOME ABOARD.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, TAMMY.
>> Tammy: THIS IS VERY
INTERESTING.
I AGREE WITH ALEXANDRIA, NO ONE
WANTS TO GO BACK, BUT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE WANTS TO GO BACK TO
HAVING THEIR JOBS DELIVERING
PIZZA, EITHER.
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
ROUGH PRIMARY, AND CERTAINLY
WOULD BE AN EVEN ROUGHER GENERAL
ELECTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HIS BIGGEST
LIABILITY IS?
IS IT HIS SKIN COLOR, HIS AGE,
IS IT BEING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PAST?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
LOOKING AT HERE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S HIS SKIN
COLOR OR HIS AGE, BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS I ENJOY HEARING ALL
THESE PEOPLE BEAT UP ON A
76-YEAR-OLD WHITE MAN, HIS
PRINCIPAL RIVAL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS A
77-YEAR-OLD WHITE MAN.
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEM
I THINK IS THAT BERNIE IS A
ROMANCE FOR HIS SUPPORTERS.
HE IS A ROMANTIC FIGURE, A
ROMANTIC, INSANE FIGURE, BUT HE
IS ROMANTIC.
BIDEN IS TIRED AND IN THE AWFUL
POSITION OF BEING UNABLE TO RUN
AS HIMSELF, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE BASICALLY
DISOWNED 90% OF WHAT JOE BIDEN
HAS BEEN DOING IN WASHINGTON THE
LAST 45 YEARS.
SO THAT'S A TERRIBLE PROBLEM FOR
A GUY, WHEN YOU HAVE TO RUN IN
AN ESSENTIALLY DISHONEST WAY,
WHICH IS WHY HE GAVE THIS A
TORTURED AND WEIRD RATIONALE AS
TO WHY HE HAS DECIDED TO GET
INTO THE RACE IN THIS VIDEO.
BERNIE HAS IT WAY EASIER.
BERNIE JUST GETS TO BE BERNIE,
AND BIDEN IS TRYING TO BE
SOMETHING OTHER THAN BIDEN.
>> Tammy: IN THE VIDEO, IT WAS
INTERESTING THAT HE REALLY
BASTED IN CHARLOTTESVILLE, BUT
IT SEEMS THAT WITH THIS FEAR
THAT ALL OF AMERICA HAD BECOME
RACIST, AND HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE MODERATE.
YET THAT IS THE RHETORIC OF THE
LEFT.
AT THE RHETORIC OF THE LEFT
REALLY, ALSO, IS KIND OF SEXIST
AND RACIST, IN A WAY.
AND AGEIST.
FOR A GROUP THAT IS POLITICALLY
CORRECT, THEY SEEM TO BE MOVING
INTO AN ARENA THAT THEY USE TO
CONDEMN PEOPLE FOR.
>> IT IS VERY INTERESTING THAT
OLD PEOPLE ARE THE LAST PEOPLE
YOU CAN BEAT UP ON.
I THINK THAT IS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT DEMOCRAT IDEOLOGY
ESSENTIALLY NOW IS LIVING IN A
KIND OF HYPE OF PRESENT TENSE,
SO THAT ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE THE DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY
IS ENTIRELY IRRELEVANT.
THAT MEANS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
EXEMPLIFY IT, YOU KNOW,
CANDIDATES WHO ARE OLDER THAN 12
YEARS OLD, CAN BE BEATEN UP ON
THE GROUNDS OF THEIR AGE.
BUT BIDEN DOESN'T EVEN DO THE
OLD THING WELL, BECAUSE LIKE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, THE BASIC
PREMISE OF THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
FEVER IT WAS THAT TRUMP WAS SOME
KIND OF DEEP SLEEPER, OR NOT SO
DEEP SLEEPER, FOR VLADIMIR PUTI
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT DOESN'T INDICT ALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
THIS WEIRD THING THAT TRUMP
SOMEHOW IS LEADING TO THIS
RESURGENCE OF WHITE SUPREMACY
NECESSARILY INDICTS NOT JUST
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OF
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OT
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OE
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OC
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OU
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OT
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OY
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION O,
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OT
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION OO
TRUMP BUT HALF THE POPULATION O.
>> Tammy: THAT'S IT AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO FIT INTO THAT.
THE OTHER OLDER WHITE MAN,
BERNIE SANDERS, LAST NIGHT I
ATTENDED AN EVENT CALLED SHE THE
PEOPLE.
A WOMAN IN THE CROWD ASKED
SANDERS WHAT HE WOULD DO TO
FIGHT AGAINST A SO-CALLED WHITE.
WHEN HE EVADED GIVING AN ANSWER,
HE BEGAN TO GET HECKLED.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> LET ME JUST FOLLOW UP,
SENATOR  .
THE CORE OF THE QUESTION IS
ABOUT, AS PRESIDENT, WHAT WOULD
YOU DO WITH THE RISE OF WHITE
SUPREMACIST VIOLENCE AND PROTECT
US?
[APPLAUSE]
>> YOU KNOW, AS SOMEBODY -- I
KNOW I DATE MYSELF A LITTLE BIT
HERE, BUT I ACTUALLY WAS AT THE
MARCH ON WASHINGTON WITH
DR. KING BACK IN 1963.
>> Tammy: HE GOT BOOED FOR
SAYING THAT, WHY?
>> BERNIE, IN FAIRNESS, HE LOOKS
FABULOUS THERE.
HE DOESN'T LOOK 77.
HE LOOKS LIKE 83, 97 MAY BE.
BUT YOU CAN TELL HE IS ACTUALLY
SERIOUS ABOUT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE LIVES ACROSS FROM THE
CONNECTICUT RIVER FROM ME AND HE
LOOKS MORE COIFFED AND GROOMED
THAN I'VE EVER SEEN HIM.
SO HE IS SERIOUS THIS TIME.
>> Tammy: I THINK HE IS READY
TO TAKE IT ON.
BUT THIS IS JUST ONE TASTE OF
WHAT EVERYONE CAN EXPECT IN THIS